c'est l'une des affaires les plus
médiatisés des états unis celle de
l'acteur johnny depp est accusé de
violence conjugale par son ex femme
amber heard johnny depp se retrouve à
nouveau devant les tribunaux face à son
ex femme l'acteur denis lépée depuis le
début a donc intenté un procès en
diffamation pour retourner les
accusations qui ont été portées contre
la plaignante monsieur med
procès filmé et retransmis à la
télévision devenu un véritable déballage
de leur vie privée sur la place publique
enregistrement audio agressions
physiques addiction à la drogue telli
sur le tapis ce soir retour sur les
éléments clés de ce concert événement
alors c'est vrai que c'est incroyable
le spécialiste people bien entendu
gilles verdez
et à johnny depp a marqué énormément de
points quand même alors la montre et
vous avez les photos peut-être il a
indiqué que elon musk celui qui a
racheté twitter avait été pris en photo
avec amber heard dans un ascenseur
pendant qu'ils étaient ensemble regardez
c'est à dire que pendant qu'ils étaient
ensemble on avait un fidèle a way dans
l'ascenseur aux erreurs des landes mais
comment ça c'est comment c'est qu'il a
su ça dans l'ascenseur il a dit la ville
a soudoyé la sécurité dont il a eu les
vidéos et les impasses et regardant les
gars ont fait exactement
méfiez vous êtes toit dans un hôtel
un hôtel c'est l'ascension d'un notaire
serveur photo c'est quoi sa faute la
première photo ces maladies c'est il a
fait tomber ses clients
il est en train de chercher son
portefeuille à notre portefeuille de
lots de mox et leur
non mais c'est vrai que là c'est dans un
hôtel ça veut dire vous rendez compte ça
veut dire donc que la sécurité de
l'hôtel a fourni
un croyable beyoncé jay-z la série lui
en tissant un ascenseur et dans les
ascenseurs faut s'en méfier
sincère quoi et dans ton cul
de four hills queens des rapaces qui au
regard de l'auteur une coloscopie merci
oui depuis après elle a dit que pour
masquer ses blessures que johnny depp et
infligeait elle était obligée de
maquiller son visage elle a cité la
palette de maquillage qu'elle utilisait
un en 2016 manque de bol cette palette
est sorti en 2010 est c'est la marque
qui l'a indiqué dans tout ce qu'elle dit
c'est faux ce sont des mensonges en
permanence amber heard c'est lui qui a
souffert il a reconnu qu'il était
intoxiqué qu'il avait des problèmes et
la discussion va revenir sur les
dernières révélations parce que là vous
dit beaucoup de choses mais vous dira
rien
affirment être une victime de violences
conjugales il a admis la semaine
dernière comme de earl avait joué un
rôle déterminant dans sa désintoxication
au zoopôle ici
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'ils
mangeaient de l'huile de l'île de piot
voilà il affirmé qu'elle avait été aussi
l'élément déclencheur de sa rechute le
majordome de la maison dans laquelle
johnny depp et sa meuf ont séjourné en
australie en mars 2015 a témoigné à la
barre il est le seul témoin d'une
bagarre présumée ayant aujourd'hui
engendré la perte d'une partie du doigt
de bonnes idées mais ouais qu'anthony
dette a perdu la partie du tournoi
jusque là bas c'est rooney
direct avec le goûter de votre cac était
cassée elle a fait comme ça craque et
c'est la coupe est un beau nom mais sans
déconner passage chez les fous ces gens
c'est bien oui c'est lui qu'a rocade est
en fait c'est le c'est le gars qui a
trouvé le doigt mais jordan mais il a
trouvé le droit de la star on le met
dans de la glace donc il a remis le
doigt il a mis le doigt dans le pot de
glace qui avait
parcouru le doigt c'est fini de ben je
sais pas médecin mais il est malgré tout
aidé a vendu quelque part elle affirmé
qu'il s'était lui-même coupé le doigt
fétichiste affaire conclue avec sophie
doit johnny depp a coûté nous
alors j'ai trouvé ça dans une brocante
alors on d'horreur d'affirmer qu'il
s'était lui-même coupé le doigt parce
qu'il était sous drogue trois jours de
suite et bien sûr johnny depp lui
affirmé que c'était lecteurs de matthieu
delormeau la bouteille est là le doigt
est parti le doigt filet il a filé non
mais c'est vrai il à filer doux vous
avez un enregistrement choc aussi qui
est sorti dans lequel johnny depp évoque
un bain de sang qui a marqué un nouveau
coup de théâtre dans cette affaire
pleine de rebondissements vous êtes au
courant de cette affaire non le bain de
sang cette bande sonore témoigne d'une
dispute passé entre johnny depp et sa
meuf son épouse de 2015 et 2007 on y
entend le héros et pirates des caraïbes
prononcé ces paroles m'éloigner
nécessaire c'est nécessaire surtout en
ce qui concerne toi et moi c'est d'une
importance capitale parce que la
prochaine étape si je ne m'en vais pas
si je ne sors pas un petit moment cela
va être un bain de sang ça n'en vaut pas
la peine donc c'est un service de fous
rires oui johnny depp il est aussi
malmené par la partie adverse qui le
qualifie de monstre qu'il est quand même
accusé de violence conjugale mais malgré
ça sa carrière n'est pas mise à l'arrêt
il continue à tourner dans des films il
va tourner dans un film français qui
sortira en 2023 donc contrairement à
d'autres ça n'a pas ni sa carrière
l'arrêt c'est plus que
de tourner dans des films à lui et le
tribunal médiatique oui les nerfs du
ciel a perdu la
forme et auteur moi je sais qu aux tic
et tac s'est embrouillé solennité il ya
un autre audio qui est sorti qui est un
audio de amber heard qui dit à johnny
depp vas-y tu es johnny depp le grand
johnny depp va dire au monde que tu es
un homme battu personne ne te croira oui
et donc du coup ça refait basculer en
disant que en fait c'est elle qui le
battait pas l' inverse et donc c'est
pour ça que ce premier vrai que est
extrêmement mais c'est sa toute
l'histoire c'est comme ça un ancien bad
boy qu'il avait fait de la prison plus
jeunes qu'ils étaient drogués qu'il
était alcoolique il a cette image là à
essayer de toute manière moi chez une
jeune fille je sors avec lui j'ai gagné
quoi qu'il arrive et effectivement elle
l'a maltraité on peut être on peut subir
des maltraitances de la part d'une femme
aussi et elle avait monté tout ces
systèmes qui a duré pendant plus de deux
ans pour essayer de piquer 150 millions
$ maintenant c'est lui qui demandent 50
millions de dollars il fera part de sa
carrière et heureusement la justice a
bien fait son travail aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que c'est elle qui avait
tout manigancé c'est et c'était là la
méchante 150 millions $ mais elle
pourrait donner 50 balais 1
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que alors de
la libération de la parole des femmes en
baie régit la raison fait beaucoup de
tort à l'appareil dessus parce que
malgré tout tout tout ce qu'a dit gilles
est vrai il ya beaucoup de zones
troubles dans leurs relations alors
évidemment la relation est toxique il y
avait beaucoup d'alcool et l'alcool
c'est catastrophique on le voit il y
avait beaucoup de drogue des champignons
hallucinogènes des cocktails de
médicaments en face interne énorme car
là-bas daniel maric
il faut se rappeler malgré tout qu'elle
a un petit pas si les deux jeunes filles
puisqu'en 2010 elle avait ajouté sa
bisexualité est là dessus évidemment
aucun problème mais sauf que la jeune
compagne avec qualité qui sape et à
chiens peuvent elles ont mais elle avait
été arrêtée à cette époque lambert pour
violence domestique ce qu'elle avait
carrément fait mal au bras une tâche à
d'autres hôtels et christidis vis dans
la violence et donc elle est quand même
très louche je vais vous tuer vous avec
johnny clegg
est sûre d elle s'enraye je peux vous
dire que c'était eux c'est whisky et et
drugs elle était pastis et champignons
oui vanessa paradis son ancien bagne on
voit là est monté au créneau en sa
faveur en expliquant qu'il ne l'avait
jamais battu témoignage très important
qui montre qu' il ya des périodes où il
n'est pas bien sur le plan personnel
mais il n'y a aucune violence conjugale
est l'ex de vanessa paradis n'a pas
témoigné non ce qui est qui dans le taxi